[Music]
my name is max altenstall and i am in
need of a new couch
but finding a new couch is not actually
that easy especially when i don't really
want to go into a whole bunch of stores
if only there was some way
that i could virtually
see a whole lot of different couch
options
hmm
i know a guy
who works at a company that i think can
help us i'm here with barry from markson
barry thanks for joining me today can
you tell me a little bit about what you
and mark sent do hi max i'm the cto and
co-founder of markson and we provide
content management systems for 3d
products
as well as applications for e-commerce
experiences for retailers and brands
specifically products for the home so if
i need a new couch because i need a new
couch
how can marxan help me do that so marxim
provides room planning applications and
augmented reality applications
and web ar experiences that let
consumers come in
and design and lay out a new floor plan
for their kitchen for their bedroom
dining room or living room and they take
3d products that are the actual products
that they can buy
from a retailer or from a manufacturer
and they can arrange those products in
the space they can try out different
styles they can switch their wall paint
their flooring and their lighting and
they can really design
their future living space and then when
they're done they can add all those
items to cart and check out on a
retailer or manufacturer's website so
that's what we do is you know bring
those uh room planing and ar experiences
to life for the home that's awesome so
that's gonna be really helpful when i
can't just go to a whole bunch of
furniture stores but i want to know what
my options are
can you walk me through what is the life
of say one couch as it goes from an idea
in some furniture designer's mind to
eventually landing in my living room
where do we start so it all starts with
a content order where we'll work with a
client who let's say wants to put 3 000
couches with different fabrics leathers
uh
different
fit you know wood finishes uh whatever
it happens to be
into their room planning application
so they'll work with us to identify what
those skus are going to be and provide
us reference materials sometimes that's
a cad
engineering drawing sometimes it's high
poly
assets that they've used for a
photography replacement
sometimes it's just photos sometimes
it's just a link to their pdp on their
website we'll take those assets and then
we'll go through a planning exercise
now planning exercise will identify with
the unique set of assets that we need to
create
to accomplish that order um one of the
things about the home space is a lot of
the products in a room can share
uh similar materials uh can share
similar sub components for instance if
you think about a sofa buying the sofa
you have the cushions you have the feet
on the sofa you have pillows that may be
shared across other items in the room
like
a love seat for instance that's styled
in the same collection right so we'll
identify even sub components
of those products that can be built once
or designed once and then reused
multiple times which really brings down
the cost and effort around
maintenance or when changes come in for
that order
so once that planning exercise is
complete
uh we'll go through a routing exercise
through our cms application very cool so
in the very beginning
retailer says here's my three thousand
couches luckily i only need one couch
but you might need three thousand
where does that come to what does it sit
in when you absorb that so the back end
of our cms is a custom relational
database uh that runs on cloud sql and
then for the file assets textures images
the reference material
3d meshes all those stored are stored in
storage cloud storage
and so the custom application is front
ended by an angular application that
runs on firebase so
all the artists
the
planners
the
analytics all those
users
you use that 3d workflow application to
manage the entire process really from
beginning to end
and then once it's published those
assets end up on
a cdn
great so
assets come in artists might be making
new textures or new models
they're all being listed in the database
and that's keeping track of how they
relate to each other this is a type of
wood or this is a type of linen
and then at some point they need to be
combined right you need to know that my
couch needs to be naugahyde because
that's very important so how are you
doing that combination
ahead of time because i'm assuming you
don't want to do it right out on demand
when i'm trying to put that couch in my
living room absolutely and that's really
one of the big lessons we learned early
on as our session started to scale that
this relational database system that we
built for
building these individual assets
is great for management great for
maintenance
great for reusability and really reduces
the effort around that content creation
life cycle but when it comes to
consumption it's really not a great
environment
to pull all those assets on demand we
even found that in many cases
pulling an individual product because of
all the reuse could end up with 50
different queries that need to be run
which could really put a large
load on a content management system so
we developed is
a compile time
set of features that would notice
whenever an artist would change one
individual you know component of a
product and then to find all the
products that would be affected by that
individual change
and then really at compile time uh just
like you have nightly you know job
services
for a devops
team would compile and basically build a
runtime version of that product that can
then be published to cdn at scale what's
nice about that is then when the end
application wants to consume that 3d
product it just downloads that
manifest and then pulls all the
individual assets it needs to render
that
without really ever affecting the core
content management operation
cool so does that mean that you're
generating new assets new composite
assets in the cloud storage buckets
tracking the relationship between the
the core pieces and the composites in
your database and then publishing the
finished composites to the cdn so that
they can be easily pulled down to my
laptop or my phone that's right and
you know we've seen big benefits with
that approach really our
servers or our applications never go
down they're taking advantage of a lot
of cache data that is deployed to cdn
we even take some of the
indexes around product lists and
the configuration of our applications to
deploy those via sqlite
so that those can be downloaded
as little mini databases when the
application starts up so we can reduce
the chattiness back and forth through
web services
as the user is experiencing the
application so really in many of these
cases once they start the application up
until they're ready to save
their end
room layout they could run in a
completely offline way and so a lot of
information can be cached and we wait
till changes happen to redownload it so
users can come into the out of the
application if no new content has been
published they're running pretty much
locally in the browser cache that sounds
like it's going to make performance for
me the consumer a lot better but also
reduce the amount that you have to send
over the network absolutely and that's
you know really what it's about is kind
of pleasing these two different uh you
know users of this platform
it's around letting the artists produce
the most amount of 3d products with the
least number of assets and then be able
to respond to changes that come in you
know from the client or from uh you know
the project team as they're deploying a
new application but at the same time
pleasing the end consumer creating as
fast downloads as we can with a minimum
number of assets and so we can create
the best quality rendering experience on
the front end
uh for the amount of assets that we're
using and in retail right if you're too
slow someone's going to wander away but
also if your systems go down that
downtime is lost money for all of your
retailer clients so how do you make sure
that your back end is reliable enough to
keep them still selling all the time
it's really about isolating that
production environment and consumption
environment from the
creation environment you know where all
the assets are built and by keeping
those separate we don't really have to
worry about downtime at all you know
when cut new content batches go out they
can be tested
uh through really an a b testing
deployment that we've
implemented and so we never really worry
about you know downtime when it comes to
consuming the assets or using the end
applications
awesome it sounds like
a pretty sophisticated system that's
mostly invisible to me as i just get to
enjoy virtual couches all over filling
my living room up to the ceiling that's
the hope it's been about 10 years in
building this environment and kind of
solving all the different problems that
we've seen
along the way with making the process
more efficient for creation and then
also making the process highly optimized
for consumption as well that's awesome
thank you barry for coming on and for
telling us this story about how these
virtual sofas can travel through that
entire cloud infrastructure to end up in
my virtual and hopefully eventually my
physical living room i really appreciate
it thanks max it's been great wow so now
i get how all those virtual couches
ended up
all over my living room oh i guess i
have to pick one now huh
well i'm really glad that barry was able
to explain how marxent is using all
these different pieces of google cloud
to power this super cool retail
experience from home if you want to
learn more about what they've done and
what many others have done on google
cloud click on the link below to see the
rest of architecting cloud solutions
thanks for watching